saying you should try to be kind sounds
like a really really silly and obvious
thing to say but everyone but an idiot
know that duh it's a sort of thing you
earning me to tell little children to
stop them be nice and brave and you know
there are better things to try to be
then kind like be create it and bending
an app but just in general being with
Hochberg kindness is for losers
this will old ladies without the
strength to be anything else now that no
one goes to church anymore we don't need
a new religion behind now we don't need
to hear that it shouldn't be greedy and
exploitative
we don't need to take a pause and
evaluate every day how our actions
affect others we don't need to hear
regularly and we shouldn't trample on
people weaker than ourselves the other
people are fragile now we need to look
after one another
because we're all we have in a cold
universe there we should be slow to
anger now we shouldn't be vicious and
horrible online cause that hurt just as
much as in a physical world that we
should try to see it from the other
person's point of view we don't need to
hear that we should stop hating dissing
insulting overlooking judging slamming
and being a turtle art we know it all
it's so obvious didn't you know
and it's not important to be quite
either because politeness is fake and
it's always better to pay and do what
you really think isn't it
no let's I have a philosophy of kindness
things are already going so well just as
they are
you